okay this week for our classic interview
we're going to go back to when I spoke
to Alec Carrick it's honest about the
bail bonds industry which is a horrible
horrible industry which I've covered
before and this is sort of in the
context of the story we've covered a
couple of times now with Shane Kavanagh
from Portland Oregon about Saudi
nationals typically students who are
charged with crimes in the United States
and end up being whisked back to Saudi
Arabia evading justice and the contrast
between those wealthy Saudis and what is
effectively a kid gloves treatment by
virtue of the Saudi authorities
involvement compared to how the average
person and particularly poor and lower
middle class people how they are treated
including by the bail bonds industry so
back to my interview from February of
2016 with Alec Carrick it's honest
take a look at this I'm joined today by
Alec Carrick it's honest who's a civil
rights lawyer dedicated to transforming
the American criminal justice system
justice system Alec we've been talking
about bail and the bail bond system in
the United States for a very long time
let's sort of start at the most
fundamental level when someone is
brought in to court what is the basis on
which the amount of bail is decided and
whether there is even bail at all so
after someone's arrested in all 50
states they're they're brought to jail
and in most circumstances they're told
you're eligible for release immediately
but you have to give us some money first
and in some places that decision is
based on a chart that is based purely on
the offense that the person has been
charged with and in other places they go
before some officers magistrate some
judge and the judge just sort of picks a
number or an amount of money and
typically that's happening without any
inquiry at all into whether the person
can afford that amount of money that's
interestingly not the case in the
District of Columbia where I live in
practice or in any of the federal courts
in any of the 50 states around the
country in those systems people are
released prior to trial without having
to pay any money unless the
that they're a danger to the community
or a risk of flight and so in the
federal system and in DC decisions about
whether a human being is kept in a cage
prior to trial are made based on
evidence and about whether they're a
danger rather than based on someone's
poverty but in all of the other states
whether you stay in jail after you're
arrested by the police
depends solely on whether you can afford
to pay bail and now explain how the bail
bond system works as you mentioned your
ability to pay that bail may vary
drastically and it often does so talk
about what service a bail bondsman
provides to someone who has been set a
bail realistically that they cannot
afford so in 46 states we have what's
called the commercial bail bond industry
there are four states that have outlawed
bail bondsman the United States and the
Philippines are the only two countries
in the world that still allow commercial
bail bondsman what this industry does is
it preys upon the people that are too
poor to afford to pay the bail that's
been set by the court they come in and
they say if you give us a percentage of
that amount we will tell the court that
we'll cover the rest
now they typically because they control
so many state legislators and local
government systems they've typically
passed rules that actually protect them
even from having to pay at all even if
you don't show up there Whiskey
virtually nothing what they then do is
they trap these people in these
incredibly onerous exploitative
contracts so sometimes they might say
you give us five percent of the money
bail and then you agree to pay us the
rest at the highest allowable interest
rate under law for years so you could be
like some of our clients you could be
arrested by the police and then you
could be held in jail on a bond you
can't afford and then you go to a bail
bondsman you make a payment and now you
owe them money for years and the very
next day the prosecutor looks at your
case and says there's no crime here or
there's not enough evidence and they
dismiss the case now you're stuck owing
money to the bail bondsman for a case
that was never prosecuted and this is
the way in which the bail bond industry
transfers billions of dollars every year
from the poorest people in our society
those people that are accused of crimes
and their families who can't afford
bale to some of the richest people in
the country the bail bond industry and
the insurance companies that underwrite
them one of the incredible circumstances
of this industry is that on the one hand
the bail bonds industry sometimes likes
to defend itself by saying listen if
you're sitting there in pretrial
detention it's going to be tougher for
you to build the strongest case possible
to defend yourself when your court date
ultimately comes at the same time though
Alec that same industry is lobbying all
the time
to put more alleged crimes under the
list qualifying for pretrial detention
unless you are able to pay bail they're
sort of creating a bigger and bigger
market for themselves aren't they they
are there are about 500,000 human beings
on any given night in this country who
are in a jail cell because they cannot
afford to pay bail that's the way the
bail industry likes it they want as many
people as possible as potential
customers so they're constantly lobbying
state and local governments for more or
another incredible thing that they do is
they lobby state and local governments
for other policies that subtly help them
so for example in the state of Louisiana
if I am arrested and brought to court
for a bail hearing the public defender
that represents me the prosecutor that's
arguing against me the sheriff that
brought me there and the judge that is
making a decision about my bail all take
by statute a percentage cut of the money
bail that's set in my case and that
statute was put into place by the bail
bond industry to give everyone in the
system an incentive to keep that bail
bond industries thriving and that's the
kind of perverse incentives that we're
seeing all over the country with the
bail bond industry now and it was really
okay go ahead yeah no no I was gonna say
what's really interesting about the
point you just made is the bail bond
industry likes to advertise itself as
helping to release people and yet in our
lawsuits after we've seen them filed we
see a lot of fear-mongering by the dáil
bond industry about about how well if
you if you get rid of the bail bond
industry you're gonna really be leasing
all these criminals which is their the
very advertising slogan that they've
been going by for years what's
fascinating about it and the reason why
a lot of police and prosecutors and
sheriffs are really opposed to the bail
industry is that if you believe that a
person is a danger to the community
and you think that person could harm
other people while they're awaiting
trial why in the world would you release
that person just because they have money
if someone is a dangerous predator I
would argue they're even more dangerous
if they have resources and money so the
bail bond industry is advocating for a
system that releases Robert Durst
but that cages Sandra bland and that is
absolutely absurd do you have data
nationally on what percentage of alleged
perpetrators are not even offered bail
in other words they're considered such a
risk to society that bail is not even an
option and then how many are offered
bail but ultimately never pay it either
directly or via bail bondsmen and how
many do pay the bail and get out do we
have some sort of sense of those numbers
no and in fact no one's keeping those
numbers precisely because of incentives
involved here and the bail bond industry
doesn't want there to be decisions made
about people's dangerousness they want
people to be offered high money bonds on
the chance they could get the money
together to pay it so when when courts
all around the country in most states
aren't ever making the determination
that someone is dangerous they're just
estimating if a judge thinks that a
person is dangerous in a state that uses
a lot of commercial money bail they'll
just estimate an amount of money that
they think the person can't afford so
they'll say you know a million dollars
on the hope that the person can't pay it
you know that very unconstitutional
obviously but that's what's happening in
courts all over the country and so no
one is keeping any kind of data right
now on the question that you asked which
is sort of what's happening to people
that are that are really dangerous and
are they being released on bail because
they're rich and things like that so we
don't really know all we know is that
the money bail system is keeping
hundreds of thousands of very low-risk
nonviolent and and otherwise and
offenders that we know through the data
aren't likely to commit new offenses why
bother pending trial in jail just
because they're poor I want to go back
to something you sort of alluded to
which is the sort of general lack of
risk that bail bondsman have for losing
money they claim right that they deserve
to earn this sort of commission
typically ten percent for helping people
get out of pretrial detention because
they are taking on risk right if the
alleged perpetrator
disappears after they've been bailed out
by the bail bondsmen bail bondsman is on
the hook for their entire bail the
reality though is that these bail
bondsman individually have insurance and
that if you look at the numbers it is
very rare that they actually are out
anything close to 100% of the bail for
any individual alleged perpetrator they
have a very solid insurance system in
place it's very true all of those
empirical claims of the bond industry
are complete fabrications the other
really interesting point is what they've
been ago she ated for it a lot of states
and a lot of jurisdictions is a grace
period so they don't have to even if the
person does skip out they don't have to
make that payment for two three four
years right and so what you see then is
they rely on the police it's very very
common in our society that the police
will then pick somebody up on a warrant
because we've got the US Marshals and
local police and sheriff's who are out
looking for people if they ever skip
court and when those people are then
brought back in by the police not by the
bail industry the bail industry doesn't
have to pay so they sort of freeride on
law enforcement to to assure themselves
of never having to put any risk up and
as you say even on the very very very
small number of cases where they are
exposed because they the person skipped
court they have insurance to protect
themselves from that and it's actually
those insurance companies not individual
bail bonds people but those insurance
companies that are providing a lot of
the lobbying and the money and the
financial support for a lot of these
these terrible policies and I think it's
yet another example it's yet another
example where there's sort of capitalism
for the profits while you socialize the
risk that's exactly right and and what's
really encouraging now is you're seeing
law enforcement leaders all over the
country the Department of Justice
federal prosecutors local sheriff's
national associations of police officers
who are speaking out against this
because the system makes absolutely no
sense it does not make sense to release
people who might be dangerous just
because they're rich it does not make
sense to hold people in a cage who might
not oh that's because they're poor we've
been speaking with Alec Carrick it's on
a civil rights lawyer thanks so much for
talking to us about this really
important issue
thanks for having me